this is dark purple of Susan strong is
back
I think it's reveal that she's human
right look look there's some sort of
weird something in her head but she had
like normal ears
yeah and stuff so I'm assuming she's
human so that's cool you go Susan um
pretty much it starts off with there's a
soda called super poor and it's just the
purple soda and I like ever wonder where
it comes from it's like now we could go
on an adventure and find out it's
definitely don't wanna so soon so strong
comes in after God knows how many
episodes you know not seeing her and she
comes back and she's got her little
crystal gems with her fighting against
super poor appear really crystal gems
it's one that the Creator worked on they
show so come on give a little they're
ripping off Futurama with this episode
anyway my sole reference another show
come on come on it's slurm or swaram
whatever it was called do you ever see
that episode Futurama the one that
ripped off oh Willy Wonka yes so the
circle continues anywho so they find
this baby that is gonna be I guess the
new mascot and they go to this Factory
it's a bunch of these very strange kind
of purple creatures that just make the
soda and they go they get the baby back
and the end decision your hairnet I said
she wasn't hearing a hair that um so uh
this is a fun adventure my big question
outside of taking the baby which yeah
that's a bad thing and everything but
what were they really doing that was
like awful like and she was like you
know no pork bad stop drinking poor
Bothell was there anything revealed that
was like no this is brainwashing um or
making him terrible or anything like
that I mean their working conditions
were obviously not good but you know
lemongrabs isn't always that great
either they get one bite for dinner and
that
that's it um so I don't know it was a
little confusing it seemed like hey
here's just an odd strange episode um
like it's the last one was so not
strange well but even then there's kind
of like this you know almost like this
existential focus on self and everything
you know this one is just gonna do some
weird you know a soda factory why
why not oh and it's fine
I liked you know a little bit more
intrigue we see Susan without her hat
and looks like I don't know what that
either a scar like a chip or something
really good ship yeah no that was put in
her head um and the seams seemingly
human um and you know it's fine it's
creative I love the designs of those
workers how they all yeah the whole
difference are the weird hind legs or
something even have like legs come out
the bags and stuff like that yep they
all have hair that's good and I like I
can't like the way they operate too like
some could speak pretty well but then
would just you know the same one that
was like no you cannot have the porv we
are told not to have the port so we're
not gonna do that when to follow the
laws but then like when she grabs Susan
she's like are you new here are you new
here are you new here I I kind of like
like trying to figure out how these
things work and what their mindset is um
so I like I kind of like how Susan
doesn't always catch on that what she's
doing isn't the prize to either like
wait why Susan waiting in line Susan did
not think this up everyone it's like cuz
I was like I do like wait yeah why is
she doing this and any time she said
that I love that you say don't you think
that cracked me up um so that's my take
now you talk about your much better
explanation about how what this was all
about how we can all benefit from it
it's actually super super deep and
brilliant
well actually I want to say this for one
I don't consider this a ripoff or even a
copy of Futurama and I like Futurama and
I actually I like that episode if you
trama a parody of Willy Wonka this one
nothing like that no they go to a pot
effect now okay they see only some no no
no they go to a soda factory where bad
stuff is happening and the workers are
kind of creepy and there's one master
when the whole thing is on the face of
the corporation and it even has a weird
name like pork and slurve
so similar wonders it's even like a
weird color isn't it isn't it orange and
Futurama and it's purple it's green
oh is it let's don't look at that's a
weirder color really thing about my new
is natural that exactly nothing about it
I would be shocked if that came from
either of those Factory it's all they
came from both that's a commendation the
two horrible make blue the only thing
that they that Susan finds weird at this
place is them wanting to take the baby
to make a new mascot no but she rested
before all she's like who's out Dre
don't drink I took her more is kind of
like she's like a health nut I won't if
you think about it you know I am I'm
hero strong I don't need that stuff in
my system I'm heroes but she could just
not have it she's telling everybody not
to drink like other health nuts do I
think about it what does a health nut
walk around going it's okay that you're
eating that stuff I don't care well I do
and I am just the epitome of great
health yeah same here
exactly so we're the only two huh what
though
so that's the only thing that's wrong
there's there's nothing that's really
bad going on there Futurama they go
there and there's basically slavery
going on and then there's also this
giant slug this is arguably
slavery I don't know it's like yeah they
are fighting but they're clearly kind of
brainwashed I would just do whatever
actually leftist and she's come from
yeah whatever that purple stuff is yeah
but that's the thing we don't find out
what it is just a pop that's the only
thing going on there you know there's
nothing else going on okay so that's all
I'm saying
and I mean I can't take the baby is
weird but it's like why didn't it just
ask somebody well then that would make
too much sense
no but that's kind of the thing
like I'm a little lost on it it just got
seems like an excuse for some cool
visuals and fun little fights and jokes
and so which is fine I mean I'm a dance
that oh the way I kind of look at it is
I mean it's almost a knock at the
overall take on pop in general with the
way that society looks at pop everyone
drinks it it's like coffee mmm everyone
drinks coffee and coffees okay because
you know it's coffee but pop is kind of
like looked down on in shy 2n cuz it's
bad for you it's not good for you but
people help me I blindly grab the do and
I start drinking the do because while
it's doing it's good do I want a
question where it comes from do I need
to know where come no it's good I don't
give a crap mmm but then there's those
people that always like to go behind the
doors to find out what's going on that
sneak around a factory trying to find
the problems that are going on there
I'll let you need to smear me and then
they'll just taste it I'm even if you
like it you can taste the bad for you in
it exactly but that's not good enough
for some people some people they have to
instead of taking the baby back and be
like I'm done and over with this I saved
the baby she ends up destroying the
entire place because you know saving the
baby wasn't good enough or proving that
this stuff isn't the best for you isn't
good enough we have to take that joy
away from everyone so you think that
Susan strong even though she saved the
baby is kind of the antihero in this
like you're not actually you think that
she's pushing her health nut NISS onto
all of this as actually kind of a bad
guy well think about it
the girl next was like and I hooked it I
mean okay I I think what you're pointing
out is like interesting commentary I'm
pointing out is I don't think I was the
original intention I think it was
supposed to be like you know Susan saves
the day gets the baby back the soda
industry was doing something bad but
they forgot outside taking the baby
which is bad obviously and still makes
no sense they forgot to put in what's
really super bad about it cuz they never
made it clear how those people's minds
work if it is slavery or it's not
they're just a part of the gunk or
whatever where the soda comes from um so
I don't know which makes me think all
the more they
were probably inspired by the Futurama
because they clearly did show where the
problems were um you know and what was
wrong with it but yeah that's why like I
mean it's still fun and funny but yeah
it's a little hard to get behind because
I'm waiting for that big reveal of like
Oh where's the real terrible thing
that's gonna make her right and you know
the baby thing is really bad and but
like you said after they get the baby
bag I destroyed this place and like why
well that's that's my thing in the
beginning you have our main characters
our heroes are good guys all enjoying
the drink mmm having fun with it saying
this is the day we wait for we're
excited when we get a new shipment and
this is great
then we go to this one health nut that
that it's like no you can't have it
because it's bad for you so I must stop
everyone from having it oh they stole
the baby okay I'm gonna go eat the baby
but that's not enough maybe if they
emphasize like the worst things it was
going to do to your body or something it
would make more sense like it slowly go
turn you purple or into monsters or
maybe like that's where those workers
came from they kept drinking and that's
what they became that would be kind of
clever but it's like but they don't do
that so because health nuts never
usually find anything because sippy it's
like smokers Walsh anthers last time I
did that smokers again smokers know
smoking is bad they don't need health
nuts and people shoving labels and
everything all over the place it's like
oh I'll quote Denis Leary oh oh
they just had vitamin C in the Missis
office and smokers aren't idiots yes 20
years ago when we really didn't know
what was going on okay nowadays people
smoke because they choose to smoke well
what I want you ready to health nut
going it's bad for you it's bad for you
Ted really duh
there is a um huh everyone knows pop is
bad for you yeah we don't need you don't
warning labels and everything and that's
my thing is that that's kind of what
Susan represents is that consistent
beating over the head that this is bad
for you this is bad for you this is
better I don't care if you like it and
you know it's bad for you you can't add
you really think that was the intent
I think so I mean think about all the
other episodes just intent there hmm
I mean yeah you can interpret you know
Deb you interpret um but I like how it's
them they're like we can totally do this
adventure but now let's not ruin it yeah
and then we get some other characters to
take over which I like always seeing
Susan strong I may not agree with what
she did but I liked seeing yeah I was
finding her again yeah like her and her
I'm perfectly disguised um I'm sort of
going off what you said there there's a
movie called a documentary on Netflix
called fed up and it's about you know
what you expect you know showing how all
these bad food is really bad free and
stuff you know big shock and the one
thing that took from that was kind of
interesting was that all these people in
Congress are trying to show that you
know the things like so dime these sugar
cereals and stuff are actually still
totally okay for you and then you know
knowing a mother is it you know
moderation like little amounts is fine
and stuff and there the movie in
scientists are very much on uShip no
it's not it is still very bad for you
but I'm with you it's you still have the
right to have it and to eat it and enjoy
it
um you know the having the kids you know
the cartoon characters out there I kind
of agree with them um like and we should
do that they had a great edit window
they had this this is what the grace
edits of all time at a documentary um no
matter what you think of it it showed
because they were trying to compare it
to the cigarettes because like you said
for years Congress with Trent or these
people try and do the same thing go to
Congress and it's fine there's no
connection whatsoever and there were
blowing smoke out their ass Bunning
stand attendant but ok the other smoker
house never or when I was I never was
able to blow smoke out man well they did
it very well
Dean um but uh so it cuts from the
famous cigarette commercial with the
Flintstones yeah to a fruity pebbles
commercial like that's inspired that's a
hike right in there that is that was so
smart
um but and it made its point like in two
seconds amazing uh but you know the
thing with that even though there are P
trying to make what everybody in the
world knows is a argument I
mean everybody it's the same thing with
a smoker uh yeah it's it's the same
thing with that supersize me movie I'm
like we really needed a movie to say
this or have we really gotten so dumb
that we need something to be spelled out
this obviously uh what the hell is even
looking this up is McDonald's health
food is Fruity Pebbles health food and
stuff Oh Congress says it's okay I mean
who is actually if you're dumb enough to
go and look up that information you
deserve every false information you get
I agree it's it's what my problem I had
was super-sized me was this guy who
pretty much ate decently healthy from
what he says all son stops eating
anything and just eats McDonald's for
all three meals it's like duh every
fight in the world I mean it's like I
eat McDonald's every once in a while and
it's like okay God may be good for me it
made me be bad for me but unless you are
actually eating that three times a day
and if you are eating that three times a
day you have more going on than just
health issues ya know I mean that's my
thought is that it has to be I'm sure
there are people that have it three
times a day yeah a lot and stuff but
again they they have to know it's bad
but it's it's kind of like uh Trump
supporter no matter what you say to them
is not the best um otherwise you know
it's like they are set in their ways
they have drank the kool-aid or the
Mountain Dew everyone that comet or the
pork savers release one sermon go ahead
they drank it and they're just gonna be
that way and yeah so it's one of those
things where it's like it's I mean I
guess it's I just don't know who thinks
that who thinks McDonald's is health
food and stuff you know and then so does
doing everything so where that smoking
is good then I think because we did have
that lie with smoking for so many years
and they so stood by that it was fine
there's no connection of death and stuff
like that and then of course this big
reveal that all of that was I
think there is this big concern about
you know our food is it as healthy as
we're saying it is and what a the first
line is very
obviously probably not to who doesn't
know this yeah yeah you have to know
nowadays with all the awareness that
they have had with organic food and
everything else a if you really want to
eat purely healthy and stuff like that
you really got to work for it and you
got a look for it anyway the hell out of
money yeah you can't just go to your
local grocery store and you know but 90%
what you get at the grocery store is
gonna be terrible for you yeah you know
I mean I just I think people know this
but so yeah but but that's my thing when
okay when I started smoking God years
ago when I was 18 actually my first
cigarette was when I was 18 that's a
totally legal yeah I was actually I had
other stuff I did never mind I guess a
you probably get high his help
oh god yes but no actually at I was 18
to start smoking and like I did it
because I was curious about it not
because some commercial told me to not
because I thought it was gonna make me
look cool not because I thought it was
good for you I was curious huh smoking I
smoked other things why don't I try this
you know and you know now I've been quit
for almost three years or two years so I
I quit cold turkey it's been two years I
don't feel a desire to go back but it's
like the entire time I smoked I knew it
was bad I know it's not good for you no
one tricked me into it and anyone that
says that they are tricked my age and on
hmm for me okay yeah yeah fair enough
but in my age no you can't you can't say
that anymore because it's everywhere and
whatnot and it's like pop it's like
everything we have so many warning
labels and people telling us that blank
is bad and this is that hell video games
are bad horror movies are bad
everything's bad for you here just a
house of sit bring all the horror movies
there and the soda that's kind of my
thing is that we've gone past the point
of like being able to enjoy yourself
because now everything is just bad for
you well I think it's I think you can
still enjoy it it more yeah oh yeah yeah
I think it's more like you know how much
do they how much do we want sacrifice of
common sense and parents just pass on
their kids hey this is bad here's where
you go to find the actual good stuff
yeah you know
and fat-free doesn't really mean healthy
you know I mean it a lot of stuff you
know it doesn't equal that everything is
bad for you in excessive amounts you
have too much air it will kill you you
have too many carrots it will kill you
like so I mean enjoy your life and do
whatever you really want to just don't
you know mess with other people and do
it in moderation well the fine thing
you're talking about the soda there I
gave up soda maybe Cowboys would be now
like maybe 10 years ago something like
that not like cold turkey I'll have one
of radio I have when I came here I'm out
doing a long time um so like I'll have
oh everyone to lap I used to have you
know a soda a day minimum yeah at some
point I'm just like you know like my I'm
feeling this in my neck it doesn't feel
good and I'm just like I don't need this
I I know I'm not addicted to a one I
just stopped drinking whenever I go out
of just get water and yeah I just it was
just like you and smokey I just did it's
like feel better it's good um so I think
it is one of those things where even
though I know they're addictive I know
bad food and smokey all that stuff is
super addictive which again I think
they're making a much stronger case for
now with food and everything but yeah I
feel like you know it can be quit you
have to know going in you have to know
you have to yeah um if you don't you're
lying
yeah I think your your books are you're
like oblivious to existence yeah which I
mean don't be wrong there's plenty of
you out there who are I'm out on that
one but um but yeah uh bottom line um
Mountain Dew is great and uh it'll kill
you but you have a nice tasty blue death
it will not kill you hey Jory you wanna
do if you look man I'm busy smoking hmm